mark is in midland texas starting this
hour off hey mark how are you
doing how are you guys good man what's
up
so new listener uh first time caller
no idea what i'm doing uh
no clue about the baby steps but just
over the last couple days what i've kind
of
started to do is i've dropped 401k i
have about
130 uh 130 000 in total debt that
includes two vehicles credit card in a
home
um i was without work
due to kova for six months uh so
are we tapped into to the reserves that
we had and uh
along along with uh you know the 401k
that we had
just to uh to keep up with deals um
so you cashed out your 401k i did i took
advantage of the uh
of the covered relief on that yeah how
much was that
uh we we were about uh
70 000 um total that we had in savings
at that point
and that's all that's all gone uh
not all of it i've got 15 uh 15 left
i have a truck that i owe two on
[Music]
okay and uh like i was saying i dropped
my 41k
to uh to zero my company does a
10 match regardless of what you know if
i put in
six they'll still match me at ten so i
figured i can catch up on that
yeah yeah oh man i'm sorry you've had a
hell of a [ __ ] you've had a hellacious
year are you back to work
uh yeah just recently started back to
work
on the truck and how much on the other
debts you shot a total of one two
on the truck yeah two on the truck four
on a credit card
um my wife's vehicle eight and then 115
on a home mortgage which is actually
being rented out at the moment and i'm
kind of break even on that why is it
being rented
i no longer live in that area oh okay
what's it worth
and uh 170.
good okay well i'm honored to have you
as a new listener sir
what do you make now that you're back to
work uh
if i stay at my current uh rate
by a 12-month period after
um taxes and everything be 80 right
lower 81.
okay good for you and are you guys
renting right now mark
where you're at or do you own no no we
actually own a piece of property
and uh we live in my wife's trailer
which is also
paid for older trailer so it that alone
kind of makes me nervous to do anything
with what we have saved
well the point of the baby steps mark it
really is this
this plan to get you guys you and your
wife on the same page
being intentional with where your
money's going getting you in a place
where you
have an extremely solid financial
foundation under you so that means no
debt
you have an emergency fund in place and
you start looking towards the future
so um so a couple of things i mean you
could start i mean you have
that 15k that when you guys pulled that
401k that what you have left
um that i would i would drop that to a
hunt to a thousand
and i would start working my way paying
off your debt
using the debt snowball which is the
smallest to the largest
and so paying off which oddly enough
we'll pay off all your debt except your
house
right that's 14. and that leaves you a
thousand dollars which is scariest crap
but you're going to be on a budget
to be able to attack from there i'd put
the house on the market that's all i'm
gonna say too is selling the house and
you can take that extra i actually
attempted
i attempted to sell the uh the the lady
in there didn't want to uh
to get out she wanted to resign the
lease so i let her
do this you know because of the times
how long is the lease up or when is the
lease up is it
a 12 month yes it's a 12 month lease so
she resigned
last spring right the thing was
oh last spring so you so a few more
months is left
then yeah you don't put it on the market
when the lease is up yeah
because that's 70 000 then you take that
money so you're out of debt
except this mortgage and she's paying
the rent right now okay
so day one with no truck payment no
credit card payment no car payment
you take all your money and squeeze it
out of your budget and you add it to
that thousand dollar account you're
gonna have ten thousand dollars saved up
real fast in your emergency fund
and then getting back to that investing
mark yeah and then you can start back
investing and
and when you sell that other house i
would use that as a down payment and
build a house
on this land that you're living on or
buy another property and sell the land
in the trailer one of the two
but i would get in a permanent home like
you said living in
old trailers got all kinds of downside
to it but i
by june i'm in a permanent home with the
equity from the sale of that other house
i'm debt-free with an emergency fund and
i'm investing again
okay that was a lot mark hold on let's
let's just throw it
when mark gets off the phone from this
call what's the very first thing
you would do immediately i would sit
down
and i would go to the computer or my
phone and i would download the um
i'm going to give you ramsey plus for a
year okay so i want you to jump into
ramsey plus and i want you to do your
budget on every dollar
the very first thing and then i want you
to do your budget again
without any truck payment car payment or
credit card payment
so you can see what i'm talking about
because if you take
those numbers and add them together and
squeeze every other dollar out that you
can
out of your budget you're gonna see that
one thousand dollars in your account is
not going to be that way for very long
but i'm gonna write the checks today
and be debt-free but the house and no
payments then i'm going to be in attack
mode from this point forward now you got
to allocate for christmas in the budget
you got to make sure stuff's done in
your budget
it's a real world budget this is
freaking december last time i noticed
that's when christmas is so you got to
do this stuff
but then you say all right with no truck
payment no car payment no credit card
payment in january
i'm gonna put four thousand dollars in
this account the next month i'm gonna
put three thousand or four thousand or
whatever it is
you're gonna be able to see that you can
do that by doing the budget
the second thing is i'm going to write
the checks and be done with those debts
the third thing is i'm going to pull
that lease out and go ahead and start
talking to that tenant let her know
to look for a place because we're going
to put the house on the market when the
lease is up period
start talking to a real estate agent in
that area and get get them ready
so that day one you that you're able to
put that thing on the market put it on
the market then when it sells i'm taking
the money from that
and buying a house over where you are or
building a house on the land whatever
your plan is over there
on that side oh by the way when you have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses saved which in your world's
about twenty thousand dollars
um and you don't have any payments but
at all
you're in a really good place to start
that restart that 401k and get that
match
and you'll be able to rebuild your
retirement that you drained oh by the
way you gotta have to pay
taxes on that money you don't have
payment you don't have a penalty
but you got taxes on seventy thousand
dollars so you have a
fifteen thousand dollar tax bill coming
up in april you gotta get ready for that
that's also something you have to
consider that may have to come out the
seventy from the sale of that house
something like that in there but all
we're doing here is just working you
right down it now we're gonna give you
ramsey plus which puts you through
financial peace university puts you in
the every dollar budgeting app
gets you community and coaches there
that you can ask questions from
we're gonna give you everything as a
gift because you've had a horrible year
and we want you to get a reset
right now mark time for you to reset
ready set go this is the dave ramsey
show